From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Saturday, March 16, 2013. My name is John Dittmer and I am here in Brooklyn, New York with
videographer John Bishop to interview Dr. H. Jack Geiger, a leading activist in the Mississippi Civil Rights Movement and in the health care field.
This interview would become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, D.C.
Dr. Geiger, we are delighted to be here today and we thank you for taking the time to talk to us.
I'd like to begin by asking you about your home and family, where you were born and raised, what your memories are.
Well, I was born in New York and raised on the Upper West Side, that bastion of liberalism in New York City.
My dad was a doctor. My mother was a microbiologist which was way ahead of her time for those years. I had an older sister.
Then I went to public schools in New York City in the neighborhood.
The public schools in those years had never heard of enrichment or any kinds of special programs.
They kept skipping me. I think I was skipped grades either four or five times. I'm not sure.
There are still some kinds of fractions that I have no idea how to do because that was one of the years that they skipped.
Then I went to one of the magnet high schools that then existed in New York, taught down at the downtown campus of City College on 23rd and Lexington.
It was one of those competitive admission exams to get there. All of the nerdy kids in New York like me had been skipped grades or whatever.
It ended up in places like Townsend Harris or Stuyvesant or the Bronx High School of Science. Those were the big three.
Townsend Harris was unique in making it even worse because they did the four years of high school in three years for some reason.
I ended up graduating from high school when I had just recently turned 14.
The good part of it was that essentially this high school was taught by City College faculty and it was a wonderful educational experience.
I still remember two of the teachers who were among the best explaining to us the colonial rape of Africa.
They were teachers who later got McCarthied under something called the Rapp-Coudert Act in New York and fired from the school system.
So there I was at 14 and something adrift. I had a Regents Scholarship that New York State offered on the basis of how you did on all the Regents exams.
And in their wisdom, no college would let me in because I was only 14 and furthermore I hadn't hardly grown high enough.
And I was in three different places chronologically, educationally and emotionally.
And one of the things I remember about that period is hanging out at night to the acute distress of my parents, hanging out on 52nd Street and listening to Billie Holiday and Lester Young and other jazz artists of the period and coming home at two or three in the morning.
My mother later told me that on occasion they would call up one of those bars or night clubs and find the bartender and ask him as nearest I can tell from what she said is Jackie Dare and wanted to be reassured that I was safe.
And in fact, everybody was very nice to me and they never served me anything but Coke and they kind of looked out for me.
But I was clearly adrift. And then one day I went to see a new play, Native Son produced by Orson Welles and Mercury Theater based on the Richard Wright novel.
And starring the burgeoning great black actor of that period, Canada Lee.
And I was so moved by that performance and that message that with the brashness of youth I somehow talked my way backstage and went to see Canada Lee.
And we must have sat there in this little dressing room in the theater for an hour and a half just talking.
That was part of what he was like. He just made himself available.
And I subsequently went to see him. He was living in a penthouse apartment on Sugar Hill at a hundred and fifty-fifth of an Edgecombe in Harlem.
And increasingly that became a kind of second home for me.
And I started to spend a lot of time there. I was adrift. I wasn't in school. I was waiting for some college somewhere to let me in.
I worked as a copyboy for the New York Times because in those years and for a while subsequently all I wanted to do was write and be a journalist.
And meanwhile things were getting my poor parents increasingly difficult at home.
My folks had gotten here from Austria and Germany respectively. My dad was ten. My mother was two or three.
But they had essentially European upbringing as I look back. And they had no clear idea what to do with a rebellious adolescent in the American system going through adolescent rebellion and kicking off on his own.
And it got more and more conflict and argument about what I was doing and how I was living.
And finally one night on a Sunday night and I can still remember I packed a small suitcase and took this subway and went up to a hundred and fifty-fifth of an Edgecombe.
I knew there was no performance that night so a cannibal would probably be there and rang his doorbell.
And when I came in said you know it is conflict and getting worse and worse. And I thought maybe I could stay here some at a time.
And he kind of looked around and said well there is a couch over there you could probably sleep there.
And after I was asleep I later learned called up my folks and said this is where I was and why didn't they let me stay there for a while because he'd be perfectly willing to send me back.
But you know where was I going to land the next time. And I guess they were so exhausted with all of this they said well kind of okay for the time being.
And I spent a lot of my time I kind of shut old back and forth ultimately between my own parental home and Canada's.
But I spent a lot of time up there and there were two parts of the learning experience for me that transformed my life.
One was to be able to sit in the corner and listen as all of these different folks came through.
Paul Robeson Langston Hughes, William Saroyan out of the theater world, other leading Adam Clayton Powell Jr., other leading political figures from the Harlem community.
And it was this most wonderful education.
Then in middle class adolescent Jewish kid from the upper west side would almost otherwise never have had that kind of a crack at.
Harlem was a blaze we are now talking 1941 thereabouts and the draft was enforced and black soldiers were being sent south to military training camps.
And Harlem was a blaze with their stories of the kinds of abuse.
They were enduring not just at the hands of other whites but from the military police and the military establishment itself.
And indeed to jump ahead in I guess it was early 1942 there was the first so-called race riot in Harlem.
It was no more a race riot than something totally different.
Do you remember that where you involved in the war?
I walked right through it which is one of the reasons I knew that this was not a race riot. Nobody paid any attention to me.
Then I was clearly white. This had been sparked by a rumor that spread like wildfire that the MPs, whether in New York or the South.
I think it was in New York that the MPs had shot a black soldier.
And the crowds just took off in rage and it was highly selective.
What he did was trash the stores mostly on 125th street that were white owned stores that had two characteristics.
They were rude and abusive to black customers and they wouldn't hire any black employees.
And a store right next to them which might be white owned or black owned that didn't behave that way was untouched.
The first kind of spontaneous demonstration that they just weren't going to take it anymore and that people wanted a different kind of experience in their own community.
Indeed, it felt abused not only by what was happening to soldiers but by this kind of colonial economy as I think they saw it.
At any rate, here were all of these people, Vito Marcantonio, the radical leader then of the New York City Council.
He was a left-winger wasn't it? Well, he grew to be, is my impression in retrospect.
And indeed, a little bit later on, the FBI came to him and asked him, threatened him in effect, to denounce Paul Robeson.
And Lee, with out of moments hesitation, said this is simply an attack to divide the black community.
And I'm not going to do it. The FBI had specifically threatened him with black listing.
We are into the early phases of McCarthy. And he was indeed blacklisted.
I remember that he was about to have the plans were in the works for a radio program sponsored by Canada Dry, the gingerbread folks,
because they were intrigued with the idea of Canada Dry presents Canada Lee.
And that got cancelled and Ed Sullivan attacked him on the air. And I guess Ed Sullivan had a McCarthy or a column in the newspapers and there as well.
And Canada grew steadily through this. I guess I should add with whatever instinct adolescents have, it turned out that
Canada Lee, whose real name was Canada Lee, out of a Jamaican family, he too had been a childhood prodigy.
And I'm a violin, as I remember being told, grew it up doing that, had his own adolescent rebellion ran away from home, became a jockey, out grew
up being a jockey, he got too big, came back to Harlem, was winning all the street fights on the street.
So he turned amateur and then pro and became over the next several years a light heavyweight contender.
And then in his last tune up fight before the title fight suffered a detachment. And that was the end of a boxing career.
Nobody in those years knew what to do about anything to do about a detachment.
Opened a restaurant, wandered around, and a couple of other things wandered into a branch of the Mercury Theatre at Orson Welles, had opened in Harlem.
And he and everybody there discovered that what he was was a gifted actor. And his first stage role, as far as I know, was as the star in a Broadway production of Native Son.
He had a brother, Lovey, who was worked for the post office, I think. And Lovey and I used to go to see the New York Giants baseball team together at the Polo Grounds, which was not that far down the street from 155th on Coogan's Bluff in Harlem.
And I could always find Lovey at the Polo Grounds because he had the biggest voice I've ever heard and he would be screaming at the batters. And I would just wander around until I got to him.
And he was my introduction to street life in Harlem, which was the other part of the education. Harlem was then essentially for all its reputation.
It was a sweet and tolerant community. And I made friends and drifted up and down the street and it was very different from the Upper West Side and a very different experience.
And I think it was a great experience to be able to see the people who were brave in their own way. Canada invited them to a party he was giving at the Penthouse.
And he's bravely made their way up to the heart of Harlem, my mother and father, to join this essentially black party. And Canada, who was very true, turned to my mother and said, you know, Mrs. Geiger, I'm divorced and we got all these people here.
Do you think you could spend a minute helping out getting stuff organized in the kitchen? And my mother spent the next two hours or more, as I remember, in the kitchen.
And I called her the next day and said, how did you like the party? She said, I had the most wonderful time. There was this man in the kitchen cooking with me and we talked and he was so comfortable and we did all the things we needed to do.
And I said, well, who was it? And she said, you know, I never got his name. So I said, describe him and she did. And I said, that was Langston Hughes. And probably the one black name that my middle class white mother was familiar with.
And she was devastated. She had spent an evening with Langston Hughes, cooking and didn't know it. They subsequently invited Canada for dinner at our house on Central Park West. This was an era where if you were going to have a black guest, which must not have happened very often, you had a alert to dormant and the elevator guy ahead of time so that they would let him in without a fuss.
And he had dinner with us there. Well, all of this was a transformative experience, both to discover the struggles that were daily for anybody black in New York and certainly in Harlem.
The movements, the politicians and the leaders and what they felt and what they were trying to do. And I had this window into it that I never would have had. I think in any other way.
And a window into the Harlem community on the streets.
Jack, what years was this?
This was where talking roughly 1940, 1941. I've jumped ahead when I talked about that 1943 riot and some of the McCarthy stuff.
And a good go ahead about this time you had been accepted by the University of Wisconsin, I believe. Right in 1941, they let me in. And Canada Lee was helpful for you.
Well, what happened was, and I think the way that worked. Yeah, he came out. Native son was on tour and playing in Madison. And I brought him to dinner at the dormitory whenever we ate.
And continued the acquaintance. But what happened? Yeah, Wisconsin. Let me in. I think I had just turned 15. It was the only place that would admit me.
I still hadn't grown much. It was just what I needed to go to a big 10 campus. You know, out in the Midwest where all the girls pated me on the head and told me to come back when I made Eagles go up.
And I remember the orientation at the University of Wisconsin was consistent of taking us out to the stadium and teaching us the football cheers.
It wasn't a stellar educational institution in those years. It's changed enormously. Obviously. Since then, that would have been September of 1941.
And in December, there was Pearl Harbor. And very shortly after that January or February of 1942, I got a letter from Bayard Rustin, A. A. Philip Randolph, great organizing deputy.
And he must have got my name from Canada somehow saying they were trying to organize on campus, on college campuses everywhere for this much overlooked first threatened March on Washington that A. A. Philip Randolph and Bayard Rustin were organizing in protest against discrimination and defense plans.
And so while being this freshman student at the University of Wisconsin in the middle of the winter, I still remember freezing my butt off, picketing the Raytheon plant on the outskirts of Madison, one of the defense plants that wouldn't hire, I think, had a sign even that said blacks need not apply, like Irish need not apply in Boston.
To pick it, that threat of a black March on Washington was so serious that what it extracted from Franklin Delano Roosevelt as president was an executive order barring racial discrimination in defense plan hiring.
And that in turn triggered a new wave of the great migration of southern black people to the north to these good jobs in defense plants. It was my first civil rights organizing experience.
Probably warned you. Okay. Next thing that happened, I was working for in the middle of everything else for the daily cardinal.
The campus newspaper, but it was a daily full scale kind of newspaper. And this young Asian man wandered in Asian student wandered in and said he couldn't find any place in Madison to live. Nobody would rent him a room or an apartment or whatever.
And I started to look into it. This was my first structured big campaign of my own and discovered that, yeah, the university Wisconsin had its own dormitories, but it also had a big network of approved off campus housing.
And it had approved for off campus housing. And that was a whole industry in Madison places that wouldn't take Jews wouldn't take blacks for heaven's sake wouldn't take Asians wouldn't take any kinds of minorities and they were on the university's list.
So it was one of the benefits of, if you will, World War II, that the contrast between the commitments that our participation in the war was supposed to represent about fighting for democracy and our behavior here at home presented an opening.
And I started this long, took about six months campaign that the university could refuse had to refuse to approve any of the places that behaved this way either they had to change or they were off the list.
And the university caved finally and it did make some difference.
Somewhere in this period, early 1943, I met, I went to Chicago and met James, I'm blocking the name, Jim Farmer, the head, the founder of core, the Congress of racial equality.
And with some of the black students and graduate students and white students at back in Madison, we started what was one of the earliest chapters of core.
And I was able to continue this kind of effort, I remember with them picketing gone with the win.
I should add about this period because it was such a strange time to be so young and in college and in the middle of all of the changes that were taking place in wartime.
And I didn't want to take money from my folks and wanted to support myself in any case.
I think Canada had helped me with some of the tuition.
Anyway, I started working at night for the Madison Capital Times, one of the two full-scale regular newspapers in Madison.
And the reason I got hired at 16 maybe, or I told them I was 16, yeah, I would have been by that time.
It started to be on a police beat, well like a lot of cities during the early part of the war, Madison had established a curfew that if you were under 18 I think, you couldn't be out on the streets after midnight or after 11 p.m.
I am probably only police reporter in the history of American journalism that had to get a special pass from the police so I could be out on the street and do my work.
Even though I was only 16, I had started out at Wisconsin in the journalism school and rapidly discovered that I was doing more than anything they could teach me at the journalism school and really true.
And so I dropped that and just kicked around in liberal arts.
By the end of 43, I was busy going to school, working at night, continuing to do some things with the campus newspaper and busy with CORE.
The draft was approaching and I started the process by the end of that year and listening in the merchant marine.
It was the only branch of anything military, quasi-military or whatever that wasn't racially segregated.
The National Maritime Union had won the fight to desegregate the ships.
And it seemed to me well really two reasons for that decision.
Number one on principle in terms of racism.
And number two, I had a pretty clear sense by this time that I really had problems with authority and I figured I would have a very difficult time in the military.
And one of the things about the merchant marine that attracted me aside from its integration was that it seemed to me to be a much more functional kind of place where rank wasn't as important as the job you did.
Things were structured occupationally not rationally. It was the opposite end of what was then the United States Navy where by definition black people could only be cooks or waiters.
And went to New York and to 43 or maybe the very beginning of 44 and went to boot camp and then to radio radar officers school on Gallops Island in Boston Harbor to learn more.
And then I went to the Morse Code and radio and everything that went with it to be a ship's radio radar officer and shipped out.
And the way it worked your first trip, you were just aside and I ended up for eight months or more on a tanker named the SS Horseshoe which is not what we called it.
And the sailor Pacific and sailed into the middle of the battle at Ulythi and carrying airplane fuel I remember and then the battle of Taclos and Gulf in the Philippines came back and went down when I had a month off, something like that.
And then I went to the Union Hiring Hall and here came an opening for a radio officer on SS Booker T. Washington Washington.
The only ship in the American fleet with a black captain Hugh Mulzac who had a master's license for years but until the war never had a ship to command and always had had to sail as a mate I guess.
And then this integrated crew of officers Hugh Mulzac as the captain, black and white mates and engineers.
And I grabbed at it with pure luck that I was in the Hiring Hall the day that came up and shipped for the next year through three trips, three or four trips at least on SS Booker T. Washington.
A name that I always thought was chosen without apparent irony given some of the things that Booker T Washington was and what the ship and the NMU were about.
Sure.
Okay.
So in 1946 I sailed on a couple of other ships, subsequent to SS Booker T. Washington, but maintained some of the friendships with shipmates from the United States.
From SS Booker T. Washington for several years thereafter came back at the end of 46.
And I knew I was going to go to college to finish college and while I was floating around on the water.
SS Booker T. Washington, oh I was about to say the other part of that experience on SS Booker T. Washington was to be in Europe with integrated crews, integrated black and white shipmates.
And to have the experience of the different kind of reception all of that had in England or Italy or France or in one case Odessa, the Soviet Union, as compared with our experiences back home.
Some clown and the warshiping administration every time SS Booker T. Washington came back to the United States, sent us to Norfolk, Virginia.
And segregated Norfolk, Virginia.
And we would undergo refueling and repairs and one time that I remember a dry dock for something.
And so we'd be there for three weeks or a little longer.
And here it was the core training I think.
Once a week we would all the officers and some of the other crew would get into our dress uniforms from the US Maritime Service, would all of the gold braids and the hats and the Sinatinny other.
And go down to the Norfolk Railroad station and integrate the white waiting room and dare them to come and arrest us.
Which they never did, but it was the first kind of direct nonviolent confronting technique that we'd used kind of in the real world as compared to the University of Wisconsin campus and made a difference.
And people would, those that weren't needed while the ship was undergoing repairs would take off and go back to New York or wherever in the North they came from and rage the railroad ticket clerks by asking for tickets to the United States.
I remember was a regular habit.
I remember taking a trip. We had a chief made a black chief made Jim Brown.
Who said he just couldn't stand being in Norfolk without a car.
His car and his home were up in Bridgeport. He had to be with the ship.
So I took the train up to Bridgeport and drove his car back to Norfolk with a couple other crew members.
Just so life would be a little bit more tolerable for him and some of the other people in the crew was my own first experience of the South, even though it wasn't deep South.
And it was a very different one than Harlem or New York.
While I was floating around on the water, I had decided that I was interested in biology and medicine.
My dad had spent a lot of time saying, I don't care what you do when you grow up as long as you don't become a doctor.
And I finally got the message that he wouldn't have been nice if you became a doctor.
And enrolled essentially as a pre-med at the University of Chicago because I wanted what I perceived to be a real education.
And I didn't think Wisconsin did that, but Chicago, University of Chicago, surely did.
And started taking all of the science courses and the pre-med courses and the like.
And I was at the same time active in two organizations, Core, in Chicago, which was having lots of struggles to open up Grant Park in the beaches and other asked by restaurant life.
And I remember much more than had been the case in Madison taking part in core efforts to integrate housing and integrate restaurants.
And what we used to do was walk into a restaurant and into racial crew and sit down.
And they would tell us they didn't serve wax and they had to leave. We had to leave all of us.
And we would go politely to all the other tables, people at tables in the restaurant and explain what was happening and suggest to them that they too could refuse to be served and just sit there unless demand management served us.
So you were inviting them to join the city? That's right. And that worked some of the time. And the same with regard to housing. So I was active with Core.
And I was active with a thing called the campus chapter of the American Veterans Committee.
The AVC was the one Veterans Organization long since Defunque, but active then.
The one Veterans Organization that wasn't like the American Legion or the Veterans of Foreign Wars at least politically and was committed to be a liberal activist integrated organization of veterans.
In retrospect, I wonder how I had the stamina to be doing much of that. Core, AVC, pre-med student, because in addition since Merchant Seaman didn't qualify for the G.I. Bill of Rights, I had to work.
I worked at night, briefly, for the Chicago Daily News. And then for the old International News Service, one of the three wire services, AP, UP, and I.N.S.
I could work from 11 at night until 7 in the morning at the INS Bureau, downtown in the Hearst Building of All Places in Chicago.
The first thing that happened is the faculty member came to us in AVC. I guess I was a civil liberties chairman of AVC on the campus.
He had a black domestic servant. She got nil. He had taken her over to the hospital and the hospital explained to him that they didn't take black patients.
University of Chicago Hospital, and we started to look into it and discovered that it was the best documented campaign I think I've ever had the opportunity to run.
We discovered that the lying in hospital, the maternity hospital, had a flat policy. No blacks. What's so ever can have their babies here and be delivered.
Billings, the big one and the scattering, all the other university hospitals, had elaborate systems for turning a black patient's away or trying to.
And sending them to Provident Hospital, the black, red and black sponsored hospital part of that black hospital network, also on the south side of Chicago.
Admitting clerks were instructed to say, oh, there's some mistake in your appointment for the outpatient clinic today. It doesn't meet today.
Or your name isn't on the list somehow. What you'd better do is go to Providence. How we learned this.
The university, the student body was probably 80% veterans. A lot of them belonged to many anyway belong to ABC.
Many of them were married in those sexist years. A lot of their wives were secretaries at the university through whom we robbed their fives blind. I had 60 pages of documentation provided by the secretary wives of veterans who were committed to this cause.
And we then followed with depositions from the admitting clerks and others. We got the records from the Medical School Admissions Committee.
They hadn't admitted a minority student in 15 years or more. And before that it had just been some tokens. And impunity was so great. This was all perfectly legal in those years, 1947.
Impunity was so great that you would find minutes of an Medical School Admissions Committee meeting in which people said, well, this black student is qualified, but we're not ready to have a black student at this time.
Written down in the record. The university, of course, claiming that the only reason they didn't have any minority students was they couldn't find anybody qualified.
And so we accumulated all of this documentation. And then went to the university and said we need to talk with you about this interracial committee of veterans about the fact that you're going to have to change this.
And the university, Stonewall, and we went all the way up to the level of the great famous allegedly liberal chancellor of the university, Robert Maynard Hutchins, who said it was appalling, but there wasn't anything he could do about it.
He couldn't issue a UK's. I still remember that phrase. And it was clear that as at a lot of places, the university, which was a huge revenue.
The new enterprise for the university wasn't fully under his control. And they stalled and stalled. And I decided to, among other things, attack the medical school admissions history and record in process.
And I went down to Howard Medical School in Washington, which had this great activist dean at the time, Dr. W. Montague Cobb.
I later heard many stories about him from Dr. Robert Smith as a student at Howard.
And I made an arrangement with Dr. W. Montague Cobb that seven or eight of the good applicants to Howard Medical School that year would also apply to the University of Chicago.
We would pay whatever fees were associated with it. And we would get copies of we AVC would get copies of their entire application, including their great point averages, their undergraduate records, their MCAT scores, their letters of reference and the like.
And we went to the medical school and said, well, we solved your problem. You're going to have a nice group of really qualified minority applicants.
And those years, there wasn't any question about race because your picture was on the application. I don't think they had a box that you checked off.
There was just right there in the open. And so we said to the medical school, not only are you going to have this nice bunch, but you're obviously going to know who you are, who they are.
But each one of them has been paired with a white veteran applicant to the medical school, grade point for grade point, MCAT score for MCAT score, et cetera. And you're not going to know who they are.
And we did that. We got copies of all those applications voluntarily and matched them. And we said, anytime you would meet a white member at that pair and not the black, you're going to have to explain publicly how come.
Yes, I skipped over the university cap stonewalling. And finally, we decided we had to go public. And on December 7th, 1947, Pearl Harbor Day to drive home the point of what the war was supposed to have been about.
We staged a student faculty strike. Almost entirely student, maybe three brave faculty members at the University of Chicago and all day strike on the campus in protest against this university policy of racial discrimination.
One of the things I remember about it is Jeremiah Stamler, Jeremiah Stamler, one of the great hypertension researchers at Northwestern University and a good liberal and radical in his own right.
He fought a two year or longer war later with the House on American Activities Committee and one appeared at eight o'clock in the morning when we were just getting ready.
I had never met him before and said he had heard about all of this, I guess, and said, I figured you guys would need a soundtrack and he had bought a soundtrack from one of the unions, which proved to be invaluable.
And so we had this big rally and it got front page in the Chicago sign. I still have the clipping.
And lots of press in the black press across the nation and a little bit of press in the times and other papers about this effort.
And everybody, I still remember all the picket signs that we had stayed up all night, manufacturing, painting. Everybody from the Catholic Newman Club to the Uncommoners League, the full spectrum was out on the campus taking part at this. It was still part of the sentiment, I think, of the times.
And still the university wouldn't budge and just pretended that they were always interested in talking with us, et cetera, et cetera.
And I finally, I don't know what took me so long, got some brains in my head. And one of the veterans' wives was the secretary to the main fundraiser for the university, the development officer.
So we got the development officer's foundation visit schedule. And his next visit was going to be to Carnegie, I think the Carnegie Foundation or Carnegie Mellon University, about two weeks hence.
So we called them up and made an appointment for a week ahead and an interracial crew of veterans from ABC, went to Pittsburgh and gave them our 60 pages of documentation and said, we are in no way trying to tell you what to do.
But we do think you might want to consider giving money to an institution that behaves in this way. And a week later, the vice president for development went on his visit to them.
And two days after that, the university called us up and said, what do you want us to do? And was this wonderful lesson in long ahead of Watergate in Follow the Money and go after the money, which is their vulnerability.
Yeah. Okay, we're back.
Okay. The reason this is of personal consequence is that this was by this time, 1948. The strike had been in December of 1947.
And I was pretty burned out working at night, going to school, doing my pre-med, doing core, doing the AVC and this struggle.
And kind of half-heartedly by this time I wasn't sure I wanted to go to medical school. And I half-heartedly applied to four medical schools in New York.
I got a call. I didn't hear anything. It was before you expected to hear. I had taken the MCATs and all of that stuff. I got a call from Dr. W. Dr. W. Montague Cobb at Howard.
And he said, you're applying to medical school and you're a big trouble, you better come see me. And I hadn't applied to Howard. I thought, how did he know?
But I went down to Washington and he showed me this letter from a vice president of the American Medical Association that had crossed his desk, calling, addressed to all of the deans, calling attention to my extracurricular activities, as I remember to phrase, carefully written, not to be actionable, and the kiss of death warning every...
And the AMA not being too swift had sent this letter to every medical school in the country, including Howard and Meharry Medical College, to two black schools, and it crossed Dr. W. Dr. W. Montague Cobb's desk.
And he understood immediately what this was all about, and what the extracurricular activities had been. And he said, you're not going to get it anywhere, and offered me a place at Howard.
And I thought about it for a week or two, and decided number one that I didn't want to take somebody else's place at Howard, which I figured inevitably that would have been.
And I had no concerns about being the only white student or whatever that wasn't the issue. And secondly, that I wasn't that sure that this is what I wanted to do to justify that possibility.
And I thanked him and said, no, maybe later. And sat down and thought about what I would do. I was a good and competent journalist. I'd had a good education in science.
And I'd started life as a journalist. I'd became the science editor, science and medicine editor of International News Service.
I worked in Chicago and then moved to their Real Head Quarters in New York. And I did that for the next four years, I think it was. And it was a gorgeous education in science.
And on top of what the academic pre-med application, because what, I read all the major journals, I covered all the major meetings. I got to interview the people who were getting Nobel prizes and last-year awards for the kind of research they were undertaking.
It was as great a way to really learn medicine from a different vantage point as one could. And near the end of that time, late 1953, I'm living in New York. I had married.
My wife's kid brother and sister were still living in what was there, broken home with an alcoholic father and a nurse aide struggling poor mother and they were preteen and adolescent.
And in constant trouble at school and I had together with Mary, my first wife said, we were constantly bailing them out. We should informally adopt them and they should live with us because otherwise it's just going to get worse and worse.
And they did. So I had these other responsibilities and we were all in New York and the kids in school and living with us.
By the end of 1953, I got interested in medicine. Again, I was getting pretty bored with what I was doing over and over again in terms of journalism covering science and medicine.
I don't mean to denigrate it. It was important. I think I did it reasonably well. I had a whole new colleague of science, set of colleagues of science reporters who were going to be provisional years later in Mississippi.
And so I assigned myself to cover the annual meeting of the Association of American Medical Colleges, which in English is all of the deans on the Willie Sutton principle, but if you wanted to go to medical school, the thing to do was to meet with all the deans.
And went to Atlantic City or wherever it was and started talking to them. And a number of the deans expressed interest, but in particular, a guy came looking for me was the dean, the one man dean of admissions committee,
at Western Reserve, which was this pioneering new curriculum. His name was Jack McCoy. And Western Reserve had introduced this radical new integrated curriculum number one in which clinical and basic science were all mixed together.
And clinical started on the first day of medical school. And secondly, the novel organizing principle with medical students were graduate students and they ought to be treated as junior colleagues. And with respect, it was the very opposite of what in those years was the classical ordinary medical school at which on the first day,
I think not just apocryphally, but for real, the dean would get up. Here are all the incoming freshmen and his speech would be, okay, every one of you look around and the guy next to you on the right next to you on the left ahead of you and behind a year from now, at least one of you will be gone.
This was the very opposite. You were going to be treated like a grown up. And I applied to Western Reserve and got admitted by Jack McCoy before we take a break. I will add, what Jack McCoy did was keep, he was this wonderful guy.
Well, first of all, a one-man admissions committee. It could have been a disaster in his hands. It was wonderful because he believed that medical school was a great straight jacket. And if you wanted any diversity on the far end, you better have it on the front end.
And so every year, he admitted a whole group, ten or twelve, at least out of a class of seventy, of what on campus were called bent arrows as compared with straight arrows, deviance of one kind or another, like me.
And he kept them for all of them for his own preceptor group, also known as COYS COOKS. There was myself. There was a small time newspaper man from somewhere in Michigan because McCoy was a press buff. There was a nurse anesthetist. And we probably had six women in the class, which was remarkable for them.
And at least three African Americans, maybe four, which was also a very unusual then. There was a rancher's son from North Dakota. There was a Baptist minister who had lost his faith and decided he would try medicine.
There was a technician from the Atomic Energy Commission. There was a guy who had slunked out under the standard curriculum that Western Reserve used to have. And Dr. McCoy thought it would be interesting to see if he did any better under the new curriculum. So he admitted it again. It was that kind of a group. And I'm forgetting some of the people.
And we moved to Cleveland and started medical school. Why don't we take a break there?
Okay. You can have a look at this in the now.
Right. So we moved to Cleveland and I started medical school at Western Reserve and discovered the advantages as a medical student, indeed, at least in being older.
Because I was going on 30 at this point. The advantage is not just to be an older, but so that you didn't panic.
But of having been out in the real world in this whole different varieties of ways, activists, merchants, seamen, journalists, whatever.
Because there were so many people, classmates, who had been to kindergarten and elementary school and high school and college and now they were in medical school. And that was most of what they knew about the world. That's changed radically since then. It's hard to find a medical student that hasn't been to India, Africa, or wherever for at least a year as things have changed.
At any rate, it's still rubbing again. I didn't put it on quite the same.
Okay. Okay.
At any rate, I still had the usual wonders and uncertainties that I think many medical students have. You are so immersed in the early years, even though you have some clinical contact of a variety of patients that you at least interview when they come to this.
And I think that you would have to give you a little bit of a review when you come visit and begin to understand that process of what am I doing here?
And is this really what I want to do in life? It's not quite what I anticipated.
I was struggling with the contrast between that and what my life had been up to then. Because one of the things striking about medical school and the medical school years for me is that with the exception of what happened, describe in a moment what happened with regard to South Africa.
And the thing is that it was in such contrast with my life up to then. And one day in the second year, I was standing on the steps of the medical school. And beyond that, you could see the teaching hospital and beyond that, you could see the city of Cleveland.
And I was offered to me to out there in the city of Cleveland and beyond this insular world of the medical school of the teaching hospital.
The whole question of who got sick and who didn't and what they got sick with and what happened to them then and why they got sick in the first place and how that was all distributed.
And I think we're all not just biological phenomena, they were social phenomena. And my past life and what I was doing now all came together.
And I thought I had invented what came to be known as social medicine. And I went to the library and I discovered that the Germans and the British had figured this out about 150 years ago and written some very famous books and papers and campaigns about it.
But it gave me some sense. It was the beginning of my sense that medicine could be should be an instrument to social change. And that if you were really serious in addition to what you did with individual patients, you had to be doing something about what are now called the social determinants of health, the social and political and economic structures that had a great deal to do with who got sick in the first place.
And why the poor were always sicker than the rich and the distribution of disease was in fact a social problem, not just a medical problem.
What, Virchow 150 years in Germany had said earlier that medicine is simply politics writ large.
And then I knew what I wanted to do, although I didn't know how to do it or what that would mean exactly.
But I was very happy still being in medical school. There were some leftovers kind of for my life as a science and medicine reporter.
Namely two people I can think of in particular that had become mentors of sort, Margaret Mead, a great anthropologist, then a guy named Barry Commoner who later ended up running for president who I had covered when he won some award for his virus research years earlier.
And he got me on to, while I was a medical student, onto some committee of the American Association for the Advancement of Science, the Triple AS, on the social responsibility of science.
And one of the people on that committee was my name Warren Weaver, who was the vice president of the Rockefeller Foundation.
And I would periodically disappear from Cleveland and be in New York, mostly what got me to New York was something different.
Western Reserve was wonderfully organized, so that all day Tuesday and Wednesday morning were no classes.
And the message from the faculty was go pursue your own medical interests. Don't study to syllabus, don't do the stuff we do in class.
And this is time you have for your own growth, which was a fine idea.
But I mentioned we still had one of my wife's kid brothers with us in Cleveland. Kitty had gone back to Chicago, the other sister.
And I had to pay for medical school. I had some kind of a fellowship that had a public relations at Sloan Kettering that I knew as a journalist had organized for me with some foundation.
But we had to live.
And so what I used to do on the first thing Tuesday morning or maybe Monday night, all of my science writer friends in New York would line up fat freelancers assignments for me.
And then I would fly to New York, stay at my folks apartment to save money and spend the next day or day and a half writing and then fly back to Cleveland in time for classes Wednesday afternoon.
And I did that. My father would say, what are you doing here? And I would say we have this day and a half off. And I'm using it to earn the money that I need.
And so I come to New York and he said they never did things like that. When I was in medical school, this will come up again.
But I also did some of this committee stuff. And Warren Weaver decided to keep trying had we had talked on one of these committees during the time that I was uncertain about what am I doing in medical school.
And he wanted to hire me as the science editor of the Rockefeller Foundation and spend my time going around the world, writing up all of the projects, medical projects that the Rockefeller Foundation was funding around the world at some huge salary.
And it was certainly tempting. And I gave it some thought. And then I had that moment of epiphany on the steps of the medical school and social medicine that put it all together.
And so I wrote Warren Weaver a letter saying, I'm not going to go to the Rockefeller Foundation, but certainly I'm grateful. And I think I should explain to you why. And I recounted this moment in that vision in the world.
Unknown to me, the Rockefeller Foundation was a major funder through one of their people, Dr. John B. Grant, a great social epidemiologist in his own right that was on the Rockefeller Foundation staff, who could lay claim in a way to being the great grandfather of community health centers because he had tried to fund one at the University of Peking, as it was then called, a rural health center.
That had failed because nobody in Peking wanted to go out into the boondocks. But he tried. And he was funding Sidney and Emily Kark and their colleagues in all places, apartheid South Africa. They were the people who had been in the process there since 1942 or three or so of inventing the contemporary community health center and what is called community oriented primary care.
The idea that medicine has a responsibility not just for the individual patient, but for the health of the whole community from which they come.
And Warren Weaver got my letter and said, well, you better know about this and sent me a bunch of reprints about what the Karks were doing in South Africa.
And I knew instantly that if social medicine was real, because the after Virchow and John Simon in London and some of the other great figures of the 19th century, the American literature, such as it was, that touched on this, was all touchy-feely talking about the whole man and the whole person.
And this and that and social medicine. It seemed wasn't anything specific that you did. It was just an attitude you had. And here was this place that seemed to me to be really doing it.
And so I went to my faculty mentors at Western Reserve and said, I want to scramble all of the elective and vacation and whatever time in the fourth year that I can to see if I can go to South Africa and do this and to their great credit.
And they said, well, wouldn't that be interesting, even if demian. And I did all my clinical clerkships and we got to the fourth year.
And this was my first exercise in grantsmanship. I realized that I had to get three places to say yes. Western Reserve had to say yes I could go.
Sidney Kark and the University of Natal Medical School, which was the one medical school for non-whites in South Africa that then existed in Durban, which was where Sidney Kark were affiliated, had to say yes I could come.
And the Rockefeller Foundation or somebody had to say yes they would pay for it.
And so I wrote, thank God this was before there were faxes or the internet or rapid intercontinental communication of any kind. It was all snail mail by and large.
And so I wrote to each of them, I mean the main ones here being South Africa and the Rockefeller Foundation.
And strongly implied that the other two had already said yes. So they all wrote me back and said well in that case okay. And I was funded and got to go.
And at this point there were more than 30 community health centers in South Africa. There had been a window of opportunity. This was before 1960 and the election of (Hendrik) Verwoerd and full scale ideological apartheid.
And in South Africa before that was as segregated and apartheid run as it was to be by and large later on. There had been a window of opportunity they had even seriously flirted in the country for a while with the idea of establishing a national health service.
And in Emily were medical students at the University of the Witwatersrand, the medical school in Johannesburg. And had taken over with other medical students.
And what is arguably the very first community health center in Alexandra Township, this peculiar black township just outside Joe Bird. That was one of the few places in South Africa then where by some cork in the law Africans could own land.
And it was hugely overcrowded and congested and a slum in housing stock terms. There had been a clinic run by some Canadian nurses. They left the medical students took it over and started what really became a community health center for that population in the thousands.
And Sidney, then still as a resident was tapped to undertake the first systematic study of what was then called Bantu Health of children, African children in South Africa, which the medical schools and the government by and large traditionally had played no attention to even though they produced most of the country's wealth.
And documented this appalling morbidity and mortality rate. And so when this window of opportunity opened they tapped Sidney and Emily and like-minded colleagues.
And Sidney started their first flagship health center, a rural health center in a place called Pholela in 500 square miles in Natal province. Halfway between Durban and Pietermaritzburg, very rural. On some of the poorest most miserable quality land in South Africa.
One of their other health centers was in a public housing project, a Zulu public housing project on the edge of Durban. And in my senior year in 1958, I went to South Africa for four and a half months.
I worked first with at Pholela and then later at the public housing, Zulu public housing project near Durban called the community called Lamontville, which was really two communities, the big Zulu housing project and a squatter community of Indians.
And I think that was one of the most people descended from India that had been imported to the tile to work in the sugar cane fields. Half a century before and there was a big Indian community in the tile as well.
So, I was a royal, a wisted decarct and started to meet some of the people from the African National Congress and the Indian National Congress. I remember.
I really had this transforming experience of what it was like to work in a place that indeed took care of thousands of individual patients, but also assume total responsibility for the entire community and the community's health, housing, food, water,
communicable disease, all of the problems of the different age groups. One needs to understand, I mentioned the papers by Virchow and John Simon.
There is a paper that belongs in that category that Sidney Kark published in those years called the Social Pathology of Syphilis.
Pholela, the Zulu community in Pholela, this rural community, scraping by attempts at subsistence farming and cattle raising on this lousy land, who's riddled with malnutrition, syphilis, tuberculosis, other and diorill disease.
And the reason for the syphilis, I said, and explained in this paper, was the political economy of South Africa, in which all of the working age men from this community and communities all over the country like it, were recruited on 11 month contracts every year to leave and work in the mines and the factories in the cities.
And under apartheid could not bring their families, lived in all male hospitals, and inevitably supported this flourishing sex industry, prostitutes, outside of the other miseries in their life.
And then for a month of year came back to Pholela and their families and spread their diseases.
And one of the great accomplishments at Pholela in particular was that in the space of about three years they totally turned all of this around.
And I had this glorious time there and then at Lamontville learning all of this, going around in the field in addition with their community health workers,
another invention of the Karks in which you took indigenous people from the community and trained them.
And they became your outreach workers and case finders and follow-up people and surveyors and a whole set of relevant tasks, your eyes and ears and operatives.
And at least a couple of days a week I would go out with the community health center I was assigned to work with.
And tour and visit one community or village or another.
They had also started a community vegetable garden.
They were distributing skim milk for which the South African government accused them of communism and this will come up again in Mississippi.
And I came back from that experience knowing what it was that I wanted to do which I thought was called International Health and come back to Africa or Southeast Asia or Latin America and do this same thing.
Beyond that and Margaret Mead and Warren Weaver and the other great folks who were mentors and helpers of necessity the medical school years were ones of relative political in activity.
And certainly then the residency years. I did my residency in medicine on the Harvard service at Harvard Medical Service at Boston City Hospital because I wanted a great teaching hospital that took care of poor people.
And as many medical students did split it to take what for most kids, kids or most residents, doctors and training was a year or the most too off to go to the NIH or somebody's lab and do clinical science.
I took a little more than two years off. I was offered a fellowship in an NIH program at Harvard University, not the medical school called the social sciences in medicine which couldn't have suited my purposes better given what I was interested in.
And I spent the next couple of years interrupting the residency to study social sciences in medicine at Harvard. All I was, I had some appointment at Boston City and a couple of afternoon a week I continued to see patients and then I came back after that for my final year of residency.
The one political activity that I remember of that time were now into 1963 was organizing in Boston for the March on Washington that finally happened.
That reminds me that I've omitted the second March on Washington which was early in the Korean War, when core and many other organizations organized to protest ritual segregation in the armed forces and threatened a March on Washington.
I can't remember if A. A. Philip Randolph was again involved but it was a larger movement than that. And the pressure of that threat was such that Harry Truman, like if FDR before [had done] with Defense Plants, Harry Truman issued the executive order integrating the armed forces.
Then in 1943 the real physical March on Washington and I helped 1963 I'm sorry and then indeed went to the March.
It came back and finished by residency. We're now in 1964 and took an appointment as a junior faculty member at the Harvard School of Public Health.
And almost immediately took a leave of absence. I think I was supposed to start August 1st and I signed the papers not only on August 1st and on the same day I think took a leave of absence because that June and July had been the organization of the Medical Committee for Human Rights.
Let's talk about that. What we have now is the Civil Rights Movement of High-Cyde Activists of the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee and others of Mississippi have decided to have a summer project where they would begin by hundreds of young people down to working community centers to help with voter registration to focus the attention of the nation in the world on the conditions that were existing for African Americans.
So there was a physician named Walter Lear who had been active before and he and you and some others started this organization the Medical Committee for Human Rights and you can take it from there.
I was called up by a physician who must have been part of that beginning process in New York, Charles Hudson.
And it called me and told me about it. It said, did I want to join in forming it? I said yes.
And they arranged they were looking for field coordinators and asked if I would come and be the field coordinator for August in Jackson.
My misgiving I remember I thought this was a good idea. There was all this activity had already started me. Cheney, Goodman and Schwerner had already happened.
And there was this irony inevitably associated with it that this was going to be effective because white lives were valuable.
And all of these white kids were coming down from the north and the country up until then hadn't cared very much if black kids were killed or black adults for that matter or black anything.
But the disappearance and then discovered murder of Michael Schwerner and Michael Schwerner and Micheal Schwerner had really registered in the National Consciousness I think.
And I always wondered if this impulse for freedom summer had grown in part from that. I think it was stimulated by it but it had probably started separately.
And there was this I think spontaneous realization by activists and civil rights oriented physicians around the country.
The number one we needed to join in this and number two one way or another these people were going to need medical care or at the least what we came to call medical presence.
The reassurance that came with knowing there were physicians around who would take care of you if need be as compared to white physicians in Mississippi in the main.
There were exceptions and the relative handful of black physicians in Mississippi.
And so with considerable trepidation I flew down in early August to Jackson.
I can't remember who had preceded me in July. Everything was in full scale operation. The office was at 12 and a half north fire street in Jackson.
And there was this steady rotating crew of physicians, social workers, psychologists, nurses coming down from the north to fan out across Mississippi for the freedom summer operation.
The freedom schools, the voter registration, the coordination with the three civil rights organizations that were involved, SNCC core and the Southern Christian Leadership Conference all under the umbrella of something called cofo, the council of federated organizations or committee of federated organizations.
I'm a great and local NAACP because I remember that summer meeting Aaron Henry for the first time.
I was being responsible for an MCHR for kind of organizing and keeping track of who came their orientation where they would go and what they would do.
I was very unstructured operation because these people were very broadly of two kinds.
There were the people who came with absolutely clear commitments over what they wanted to do. And one of the great virtues was all of these medical health professional eyes in the broader sense.
We were able to document and send back home in effect reports of how brutal the conditions were medically environmentally, socially and economically and politically, simply by being there and looking around.
In many ways to me it was reminiscent of much of what I had seen in South Africa, not only politically but in terms of the circumstances under which people of color were living in both places.
That was the major group of people who came there to find a way, one way or the other to do this work.
And then there was a smaller segment who came probably with the same commitments and the same impulses but who were really there.
I don't know how to describe it for show. What I have in mind, we were all, as a matter of course, living with families in the black community.
But there were the intermittently people who came down and from New York or Buffalo or wherever they came from, Massachusetts.
And I said, I don't want to do that and rented wealthy doctors or dentists or whatever and rented motel rooms.
And I remember there was this guy and he refused and was going to rent a motel room and a whole bunch of us that were living under constrained circumstances and a burden on black families in the Jackson community.
We didn't have a whole lot of resources and we said, well, that's great. This guy has this fancy motel room with a shower and we are all going to come and take showers there.
It was hot and sweaty and we didn't have that opportunity. And I walked in there for the shower and this guy was on the phone with his wife back home, sounding very irritated and saying to his wife, how can you be sleeping when I'm down here, freedom fighting?
Well, that was a minor commitment but there were some of those people too.
And for me, it was a long look around. At that point, I didn't get out of Jackson that many times but enough in Hines County and some of the adjoining rural areas to realize almost immediately that I didn't have to go.
I didn't have to go to Africa, Latin America or South America. We had it all here. It was different than when I had been say in Norfolk or in Galveston, Texas when I was a merchant seamen and my ship came there.
Because this was an on the ground, continuous kind of experience in and within the black community. If anything, a contrast of sorts with my earlier experience in Harlem.
And there were all of these different people, Tom Levin, Jov finer, other names that I remember from that period. I don't think I met Joe Disparti or Phyllis Cunningham. Then that came a little later.
Nurses, yes, who were part of the medical committee for human rights. And at the end of that time, August, oh, I had recruited, because part of the task before you went was to help in the task of finding people all I was a steady flow.
I had recruited Dr. Count D. Gibson Jr. That's important to what subsequently happened. Dr. Count D. Gibson Jr was chairman of the Department of Preventive Medicine at Tufts Medical School in Boston, a native of Georgia.
And a remarkably solid and committed person racially, now up in Boston. I later was to learn to jump ahead from Susan M. Reverby, the great historian of Tuskegee in the Tuskegee study, who in the course of her, more recent research, had come across what she believes is the first letter of person.
And she wrote a protest from a white physician anywhere against the Tuskegee study written by Dr. Count D. Gibson Jr when he was a junior faculty member at the University of Virginia.
What was Tuskegee study now infamous was a major study mostly in Alabama, operating nominally out of the Tuskegee Institute and hospital and its black doctors.
And mostly as a major undertaking of the United States Public Health Service to study what was described as the natural history of syphilis in a black population and marred by every ethical and racist error that one could imagine.
In which black sharecroppers in Alabama, whole population of black sharecroppers in Alabama were indeed diagnosed with syphilis.
And even after early on, the availability of penicillin denied, first of all, informed consent or any knowledge of what was going on or any effective participation in what was happening, denied treatment with antibiotics, which could have cured their syphilis because we already knew that penicillin did.
And so, on the grounds that if you wanted to study the natural history and the underlying premise was that the natural history of syphilis was different in black populations than in white.
And in point of fact, the natural history of syphilis had already been thoroughly studied and published in Scandinavia and elsewhere.
And so, the very scientific premise of the study was flawed and racist.
And this wasn't the secret stuff if they were publishing in journals.
They were publishing in journals.
And God Gibson was one of the earliest people that wrote a letter saying this is wrong on multiple counts.
I didn't know that at the time.
Count never mentioned it. This Susan Reverby, the historian discovered it decades later.
Anyway, I recruited Count to be one of the people while I was there.
And Count was extraordinarily useful because from day one, his southern accent got deeper.
It came back and got intensified.
Part of what went on in Mississippi during those years, worth noting, was a thing called the the COFO creep.
Mississippi had a law that you had to stop.
You're driving. You had to stop at any set of railroad tracks before proceeding.
And nobody from Mississippi paid any attention to that because there were railroad spurs all over the place and you just went over them.
But if you were part of the movement, black and certainly black activists, SNCC or cofo or SCLC or MCHR or whatever.
And you didn't stop. The cops would, if there were cops around, they would arrest you for violating that law.
Well, the difficulty with it is if you really stopped, you were giving away to everybody in the world that you weren't from Mississippi.
You were one of these foreign agitators and setting yourself up for trouble.
So what started to happen was you wouldn't really stop but you would kind of slow down a whole lot and then just tremble across the tracks and then pick up and go.
Got to be known as the the COFO creep.
Whenever cops stopped us, if a bunch of us were in a car, we would shove Count's head out the window and in this deep southern accent, he would ask them what the problem was.
And that was helpful. And Count was good at it. And out of his own memories, I'm sure, of Georgia, this brought a lot of impulses back to him.
The summer ended. I came back to Boston to start my job at Harvard.
A national ongoing medical committee for human rights was being organized with headquarters in New York.
And I'm blocking Al Moldovan, Esther, a variety of other people as staff, senior staff and organizers.
And I took some part in that and emerged. I don't remember how. It's something called I think the National Field Coordinator, some such title for ongoing and continuing involvement.
There were MCHR chapters in a lot of cities including Boston. And Count and I, among other people that had been involved in Freedom Summer,
they had come back to Mississippi. Weekends, various local Mississippi meetings or organizations, whether SNCC or CORE.
And in particular, the staff of the Delta Ministry of the National Council of Churches, Warren McKenna, and don't remember many of the other names.
Which had an office in New Resources. And was active. And this was a period, as I remember it, in the fall, when there was a kind of malaise.
It's not that activity had stopped. But there was a kind of, well, what do we do now after Freedom Summer? And this was six months before.
No, not that many months, a few months before we had Selma and the Voting Rights Act and all of that governmental change.
And most of the Freedom Summer folks had gone home, some stayed on. And then in December, the Delta Ministry organized a meeting in Greenville
of a lot of the leftover people from Freedom Summer, Indigenous, and folks like Count and myself from outside.
I don't fully remember the time sequence. But somewhere in that period, Count and I started organizing a little too bit, but real, free clinic in Mound Bayou near Tchula in Holmes County,
at what was an old plantation that for some reason had some history as a liberal focus.
With, under the sponsorship of the Medical Committee for Human Rights, with money from wealthy supporters, and Bethesda, the Luke and Ruth Wilson, Luke and Ruth Wilson, who funded it in the name of one of their doctors or dentists, Dr. Winnick.
And this was called the Winnick Clinic, I remember, staffed by nurses, including Joe Disparti and Phyllis Cunningham, just doing free medical care, with some support from Dr. Robert Smith and Black Physician in Jackson,
and had been the linchpin of MCHR's work during Freedom Summer because he was a licensed Black Physician in Mississippi licensed as the key word, where the rest of us were not, and was fearless and brave and confrontational, and was constantly being hassled by the police.
And confronting them, he wasn't the only one, certainly, Andy Anderson and others were involved, but he was the chief one. Bob came out to Mound Bayou, the other person, who was there a lot, was a Black Physician from Los Angeles, that had come to me.
I think in Jackson, that I recruited named Dr. Alvin F. Poussaint, a psychiatrist by training, and he spent a good bit of time, he became first kind of the permanent MCHR representative in Jackson, but also working in Mound Bayou.
That was all beginning to happen, and then in December, the Delta Ministry organized this meeting, and it's facility in Greenville, Mississippi, to deal with this issue of what do we do now?
And the medical people I remember included Counting Myself and Desmond Callan, and I'm sure several others, Physicians from the Movement, and probably some of the nurses, as well as a variety of Mississippi civil rights folk.
And somewhere in the second day, we were floundering.
And somewhere in the second day, I remember having a headache, and then the headache went away because I unblocked for the first time in this whole sequence.
I remembered Pholela, and the community health centers in South Africa, and kind of learned it out, what really needs to happen is that a good Northern Medical School should come down here and start a comprehensive community health center.
And everybody said, kind of, what is that? And I described it, this concept of care for the individual and care for community, the integration of clinical medicine and public health, and the attention indeed to the environment, but also to the social and political and economic environment.
And then other people, Descal and I remember a particular started to chip in with other ideas, and the root in this, that was a particular importance, was the idea of community involvement and community participation, and words like community control being rooted about for the first time in these kinds of discussions.
And everybody kind of said, I think Dr. Robert Smith was there, yes.
I don't know if Aaron was in Jackson yet, or if he was there, I do remember Bob, Robert Smith, a doctor, and then everybody kind of ran, talked around a room and said, and chipped in ideas, and said, well, you got to do that, or we got to do that.
But it was, I don't want to say not just the pipe green, it had a quality of abstraction. Yeah, this is something that ought to happen, but that didn't mean there were any concrete steps that got formulated as that meeting in any way to make it happen.
And Count and I left, and we're flying back to Boston, and we got grounded by fog in Atlanta and rented a hotel room, and Count said to me, let's talk about the deal. I said, what deal?
He said, if we don't have any money at Tufts, if you can find the money, Tufts will sponsor it.
And all of a sudden with that, it became something of a project. And so I sat down and kind of formulated an outline in my head of how to describe this.
And what carried over when we got to OEO was that specific question of community participation and community involvement.
Now by OEO, I mean, the Office of Economic Opportunity, which was the war on poverty.
Right.
Where there was this new government agency that, among other things, was not going to be a Stodgy bureaucracy, was going to be staffed with relative professional government and from outside government activists under Lyndon Johnson's sponsorship and passed by the Congress.
And with the ongoing debate about the principle of maximum feasible participation of the poor.
And the idea that you did this with people, that for people.
And that the people and the communities would have a real voice. That was the talk at any rate.
And once I had a kind of proposal in my head, I went to the only relevant source that I knew in the administration, which was Dr. William Kissick, who was then heading the big Appalachian initiative of the administration.
And told him about this and said, this is what ought to be funded. And this is what a community health center is. And this is what the community dimensions of it are.
And he called up Elizabeth Shore, who had been working with the AFLCIO in Washington. And it was just about to join OEO. I don't think she had officially joined yet.
And the story that Elizabeth Shore later reported that Bill Kisik was called her up and said, there's a wild man in my office named Jack Geiger, And he's got this crazy idea. He better come and talk to you folks.
And Elizabeth Shore, we must have talked on the phone, she arranged an appointment for me in January of 65 with Sanford "Sandy" Kravitz.
Sanford "Sandy" Kravitz was the head of the research and demonstration unit at OEO, which had this brand new set of offices on L Street or M Street somewhere in Washington.
And I went to see him with this yellow pad. And I think I must have talked to him for two and a half hours, like now, laying out what a community health center was, what the models were from South Africa, what it would do.
And with Wyatt Belong, as part of what OEO already had defined as its community action program. And there were community action program branches starting to be formed wherever OEO was working around the country.
But there was never a health component.
OEO had no health component. And the background, although I don't remember Kravitz saying this, was that in the beginning,
the drivers belief, Dr. Julius B. Richmond's belief, R. Sargent Shriver Jr, Kennedy's brother-in-law, the head of the War on Poverty, OEO.
And Dr. Julius B. Richmond, Dr. Julius B. Richmond, pediatrician professor from Chicago, Harvard then, who was heading head start, one of the major War on Poverty initiatives.
And their belief in the beginning was that HEW, Health Education and welfare was responsible for doing things about the health of poor people and taking care of it.
And although I didn't know it at the time, the background of information was that coming to OEO, head start, OEO was just in the process through what was happening in Head Start and the job core very early.
It was how devastating the level of illness and unattended illness and care was for black children and for black adolescents, at the very least, in the job core.
There were huge rates in the 65% level of serious, not minor unattended health problems.
And I think that helped to shape some of the subsequent discussions.
At the end of this discussion, Sanford "Sandy" Kravitz said to me, well, what do you want?
And I was having some infusion of classic academic jitters and said, well, I think the way to begin would be with $30,000 for years,
feasibility study, which was the classic academic maneuver of what you did when you weren't sure what you were going to do or how you were going to do it.
And saying, heavens, Sandy said, you can't have $30,000 for feasibility study. And I said, why not? And he said, because you're going to take $300,000 and do it now.
Everybody needs to hear something like that once in their life. And I went back to Boston and I had not sat down and figured out what a budget would be for this.
And then a second thing happened, which was that when the minute we thought about it, we realized that if Tufts Medical School was going to undertake a project of this kind,
like 15 hundred miles away in Mississippi or Alabama or somewhere, that there were two sets of predictable screams, one from the White Southern government, wherever it was.
And the other from poor people in Boston saying, what are you doing 15 hundred miles away when we're sitting on your doorstep? And we realized that we had to add a second component.
And so I sat down over the next two or three weeks and wrote the first grant application for two community health centers.
I hadn't been back to see Kravitz or anybody else at OEO in the meantime.
The first Southern rural, for reasons I'll tell you in a moment. And the second at the Columbia Point Housing Project, Housing Project of eight or 9,000 people, four miles from downtown Boston, with which Count and Tufts Department of Preventive Medicine had had an ongoing relationship of home visiting and care.
I deal in a number of respects. It had no doctors. It took hours and hours for people from there to get to any one of the major teaching hospitals, Boston City, Mass General Children's in downtown Boston and wait to be seen and get back six hours. It turned out when we did a formal study.
It was on this isolated peninsula, jutting out into Dorchester Harbor. And it was in the congressional district of John McCormack, the then speaker of the House of Representatives.
One of the things that I brought to this and all of these kinds of efforts was so useful with my prior career as a journalist. I had learned then to pay attention to political phenomenon of this kind, which wasn't part of most people's medical education.
And in the end of January, I reappeared at OEO. I had said 30,000 Sanford Kravitz. It said 300,000. I appeared with a budget for 1.2 million.
And they swallowed hard. The reason for calling it Southern Rural, which I had already figured out, really wanted to go to Mississippi. Obviously it was what I had some experience of.
And what everybody perceived as the belly of the beast, the worst of the problems and the worst of the racism and the worst of the need.
OEO grants had to be circulated through the relevant wherever they were located, through the relevant congressional delegations.
And which would be a tip off, I mean, any relevant delegation, but certainly in the case of the South, because the relevant political fact here was that the Southern governors were vehemently opposed to OEO.
And correctly read the community action participation principle. As meaning here was a government agency for the first time that would be funding and involving, and possibly being led on the ground by black people and black communities without going through all of their gatekeepers, whether black or white in the traditional political hand be down.
And when the legislation was being argued in the Congress had insisted on the right of a governor to veto any OEO project headed for their state.
And of course they would know about it if it circulated through the congressional delegation in advance. And R. Sargent Shriver Jr, or whoever would be the head of OEO, had the right the power in the legislation to override that veto.
And that did happen intermittently, but it was political capital that had to be expended really cautiously, because OEO was on an annual budget that had to be renewed in the Congress every year, and you spent too much political capital, and you would be out of business.
And so I had listed it as Southern rural. That meant 10 different states. You didn't have to go through all those congressional delegations. The site hadn't been picked yet.
In the ensuing weeks, two things happened. There was a go ahead for Columbia Point. The OEO and R. Sargent Shriver Jr had no problem with that. Although it was evident that Shriver had considerable reservations about getting into the health arena.
And I was, his first difficulty. And I'm sure in fighting in the government from HEW, health education and welfare then, and from the public health establishment in general, the state public health officers and all the rest, seeing this as an incursion on their turf despite the fact that they didn't provide in the main clinical care.
It was immunizations and infectious disease control and the like, but not the treatment of sick people. That was a long division in medicine that is worth noting in the evolution of all of this.
There had been the Milbank Funds centers in urban cities that distributed milk. There was in Boston a set of things called the George White Health Centers, whose slogan carved in stone on one of their buildings that I took a picture of, whose slogan was no diagnoses made, no prescriptions written.
As a way to reassure the medical community that they weren't taking patients away from them in this division. Okay, you can have public health, but don't steal our patients and our incomes.
And beyond concerns about getting into health of all things, a striver was livery about going to Mississippi. And knowing where we had all come from in terms of MCHR and the like, he had a provision written into the grant that said he reserved the right of formal approval.
So we went back to Boston and started organizing Columbia Point as the first health center. The grant had finally been formally approved except for the Southern site choice on June 11th, 1965.
So we started working to Boston Public Housing Authority to renovate three apartments in one of the buildings of this public housing project into a health center.
So meanwhile, and started that whole process. And there was a lot of attendant publicity in Boston because this was the first health center grant, the first word of anybody anywhere about community health centers and these terms.
And the John McCormack was on board. Julia's Richmond was on board for that part of it. We meanwhile were looking at data from about six states in the south.
And I think count out of history had a little bit of a bias toward Georgia. And we actually went and made field visits at a four county area, four tiny counties near near around Sparta, Georgia.
And they wanted to. And they wanted us because they thought we were some kind of a hillburton hospital that we would bring to them. Let me back up in the process of organizing.
Okay, we're going. Okay, I mentioned that we were working with the Boston Housing Authority. I got a call out of the blue from a man named Dr. John W. Hatch, who was the deputy director of community relations at the Boston Housing Authority asking me if all the southern positions were filled yet as if we had filled one. We didn't even know where we were going yet.
Because the grant proposal had circulated through the housing authority. John saw it. Dr. John W. Hatch in my book, the most brilliant community organizer in the country. And certainly the most brilliant. I have ever met unknown or work with.
I came out of Alabama and Kentucky went to Atlanta University. Oh, first he went to law school in Kentucky. And in Lexington, I would guess it was after suing.
Because the law school admitted only whites. They set up a separate law school for him, which was a sham. Then they yielded and said, okay, he could go to the regular law school, but he had to promise to sit by himself in the corner.
And one of the stories, John told me was that on the first day, half the class came and sat next to him, half the white class. And he was moved by that.
I suspect strongly that John had an early activist career because he told me when he joined the army, he went to Korea as an environmental or specialist of technical specialist of some kind.
That his mother said, thank God you're going over to work. Because if you stay here, you're going to get killed.
And John then decided the law school was a sham. Left that, went to Atlanta University, got a degree in social work community organization.
And came to Boston where he was an organizer first in the South End and then with the public housing authority and then saw this grant. And called me up and came to see me.
And we hired him instantly. And John was the first person in our group to go to Sparta, Georgia where he had to stand at the back door of the country club, which was the main restaurant in town, in order to get food.
The segregation was still in full bloom. And later on when we decided it was worth exploring further and they were very eager in the local medical community for whatever reason to have us.
Count and I went down accompanied by John and we all had dinner at the country club. You dangled a hospital as they thought it was in front of them and they were willing to stretch the bounds of racial segregation.
The other thing that had happened in the meantime that needs to be mentioned on behalf of both MCHR and a lot of other people was Selma.
And I in a reprise of what happened to me in Canada, Lee's apartment in a way I had flown to Selma.
We knew after before the massacre on the Edmund Pettus Bridge.
And the next day you knew that Dr. King was coming. MCHR physician was a physician had to be next to Dr. King at all times because somebody was going to try and kill him.
And I flew back to Atlanta and met him and flew in the plane with him to Montgomery. And then they had sent a car for him. And he said come ride with me. I had no other way to get back to Selma.
And I didn't even have like a lot of folks any secure place to say. So King said, well come with me. You know, we'll find a place wherever I'm going.
And so I went to whatever was the activist headquarters. And I got to sit in the corner and listen that night to the long heated crucial discussion among King and the young James Forman.
And I think Hosea Williams was there. I'm not sure about John Lewis for a reason I'll get to but somebody from SNCC was there about what to do now. And there were all of these tensions and struggles playing out.
The activist group especially from SNCC but not limited to them, that wanted to confront. There was already an injunction. Don't march across the bridge. Don't march to Montgomery about what to do about that. And they wanted to violate it.
And King wasn't certain but didn't for the beginning. Think that was a good idea. And there was further as an undertone, a good bit of SNCC in particular. And court of some extent resentment of King and coming in at this stage and getting all the attention and publicity when they had done all the grunt and soldier work.
And there were people who were beaten up on the bridge and in Selma. And this went on for hours. And I got to listen to it. With a final tentative decision.
Not to violate the injunction. King as meanwhile, I'm sure, talking on the phone to Lyndon Johnson.
every day in front of the cameras, and there were now cameras,
to march up to the police line and kneel and pray,
and be a presence and get filmed every day while the political struggle back in
Washington went on. And Selma was all other things aside for me,
and worth mentioning, I think for a lot of other people, a seminal
experience, the filming of what happened on the bridge, and everything that the ABC
television network did to get it on the air that Sunday night struck such a national
court. I don't think there's any event quite like this, what came to be 10,000 people
came from all over the country to demonstrate at Selma, this kind of
moral outpouring. Stimulated further, I think, by the murder of
the Boston minister, Reverend James J. Reeb, and in addition, a couple of days later,
I got arrested by the Alabama police in Selma,
and hauled off with another physician, MCHR physician Dr. Richard Hausknecht,
to meet with the leaders of the Alabama, or the, it was Alabama, a medical society,
who felt that the MCHR presence was a public statement that white doctors wouldn't take care
of injured black people, and threatened us with further immediate and further jail, if we so much,
as touched anybody medically. And I remember on the one hand, it was frightening in the sense that
it was quite clear they were prepared to throw us in jail, so it was what a couple of local
whites who would beat us up. On the other hand, I pointed out to them that Alabama had
a good Samaritan law, which said any doctor could take care of anybody in an emergency,
whether they were licensed or not, that was part of the oath and part of the law, and most
dates had it. And they didn't know I knew that or hadn't thought of it, and it just ended,
but apparently the arrest was the cause of the Big Rally in Boston over the fact that I had been
arrested. More importantly than that, that was when I first met John Lewis, and realized that he
had suffered yet another probable skull fracture. It was a real skull fracture on the Edmund Pettus
Bridge two days before. It wasn't a depressed skull fracture, thank God. And count, and I, count
ahead by this time, come to Selma, count, and I organized to send him and Ivanhoe Donaldson
to Boston to be hospitalized and examined and treated.
And I didn't see John Lewis again for another 30 years, I think, but we remembered each other,
and he certainly remembered all of that. Dr. John W. Hatch called.
And we are struggling with Shriver. He is continuing to waffle. We are looking in places
in Mississippi where I really wanted to go. There was a limitation. The Congress in its wisdom,
it said, OEO money couldn't be spent for Brooks and Mortar. And wisely, because they didn't want
all this money to go for somebody to build buildings. They wanted it to go for services to needy
communities. But it turned out that OEO was willing to be flexible about renovation. So I kept
looking for some place I could renovate in Mississippi. And somebody told me there were some unfinished
buildings in Mound Bayou, a place I had never heard of, for what had been planned to be the JC Campbell
Junior College that had run out of money and were concrete shelves just sitting there. That sounded
good. And that was how I learned about Mound Bayou. And I went there, flew down to Memphis,
got a car, and drove to Mound Bayou, and discovered, first person I talked to was father
Guidry, the Catholic priest, who came out to see me as I was wandering around, and discovered
there was this hospital. That this was an all black town. It had its own town government.
People there could vote. They had some relative, if small, degree of autonomy.
And maybe there was a place that could be renovated, but this looked ideal from multiple points of view.
We would have the shelter and protection of a black local government for what would
inevitably be an integrated crew of doctors and nurses and whomever.
And we would need to hospitalize people. And here was this small 40-bed black hospital run by
a black fraternal order, the Knights and Daughters of Taber, building that, which started out like so
many, selling burial insurance at two bucks a week or two bucks a month, and had somewhere in
the early 1940s built this hospital, which was a real huge need because blacks had no place to go,
except the state institutions, which of course were segregated and miserable, or occasionally trailers
run by some alcoholic local white doctor, or the basement of some existing county hospital
institution, and started selling in effect health insurance as well as burial insurance. And
there it was. I knew nothing more about it at the point, but it certainly looked good. The problem
with the JC Campbell was twofold. They work on creek shelves. The Bishops, AME Bishops attempt to
build it had run out of money. It turned out they were in receivership in some white law firm in
Jackson that wanted millions for them and they weren't too suitable anyway. And so I started
to try and figure out how we would get around that. And for the first time, proposed
mom by you to the OEO, but kept all of that secret from Mississippi. I made took care that no copy of
that grant ever went to Mississippi or circulated in Mississippi or there was any news about it at that
stage. Shriver still hadn't signed off and was stonewalling. And I finally, by this time,
this is now early 1965. On December 11th, early 1966, I'm sorry, late 1965.
Point out that in 1965, the Head Start program in Mississippi, child development group of Mississippi
was the most successful in the nation, but it came under severe attack from Senator John C. Stennis.
And OEO was liarry of anything going into Mississippi to go up against that power.
Right. And indeed, Senator John C. Stennis and Mississippi had started their own rival head start organization.
And it was a subject of bitter controversy and this will come up again.
And so we had opened Columbia Point on December 11th, 1965, exactly one year
from the meeting in Greenville under the auspices to the day, under the auspices of the Delta
Ministry. The grant had been approved with the site approval reservation on June 11th and
six month later, John McCormack spoke, Dr. Julius B. Richmond spoke, I spoke, national publicity and community
health centers were launched. During that ensuing 12 months, there were applications for community
health centers from Watts and UCLA in Los Angeles from a Rush Medical School and the Mile Square
community on the Southside of Chicago from Denver University of Colorado and the Denver Health
Department and from Albert Einstein, Manifior in the South Bronx. All under discussion are starting
to be funded as research and demonstration projects because there was no authorization
for OEO to be doing this other than as a research and demonstration rubric. So this was all
Sanford "Sandy" Kravitz and Dr. Julius B. Richmond. Meanwhile, R. Sargent Shriver Jr kept holding us up. And so one day
I looked up the schedule and made sure that R. Sargent Shriver Jr was scheduled to be testifying on the hill
and that was going to take all afternoon. And R. Sargent Shriver Jr had post-pulled meetings with me and
wouldn't give site approval or even discuss it because of his anxiety about Mississippi.
I took the vice president and he was also some kind of a dean,
a trendendic his name was I think. I took the vice president of Tufts with me and we flew
down to Washington and stayed just sitting in R. Sargent Shriver Jr's office. Walk right past the secretary and sat
down. As somebody observed later, it was the first time in all of the 60s that the dean was sitting
in, not the students. And R. Sargent Shriver Jr had to deal with us so he couldn't use his office and
we wouldn't budge. So he came back, he was told about this immediately. I'm sure came back
and handed us over to Dr. Julius B. Richmond, the deputy director of OEO and the head start.
And I spent the rest of that afternoon and I should add, Trinidadic said,
applied real pressure angrily saying you have no business treating a major university this way
and we will tell every other university and that was leverage. So he handed us over to Julie
Richmond and I spent that afternoon talking to Dr. Julius B. Richmond and worked out an agreement. I don't
remember that I had to give anything away beyond the conventional assurances that we weren't,
the civil rights organization, we were a health organization. Remember this was not formally
MCHR, this was Tufts. And OEO took comfort all of the first five grants were to medical schools.
It gave them cover, it assured quality. And they saw that as a way to proceed. At about
nine o'clock that evening, Julie said, okay, I will, I had sketched out the agreement, we had
worked that out together and you know, a pad. And he said in the morning, I'll give it to the
secretaries and they can type it up and we'll bring it to R. Sargent Shriver Jr. And I thought to myself,
no way. And I said, Julie, it's okay, I type 100 words a minute. You find me a typewriter and I'll
just sit down and do it now. And his jaw dropped but there it was and I sat down and I typed it out
and he took it up to R. Sargent Shriver Jr who was still in his office and he must in addition have said,
I recommend we do this because he was critical to accomplish that step. And R. Sargent Shriver Jr signed it
and sent it back down with a little note, congratulating me for my tenacity accompanied by a little
gift of fruit which I later realized was raspberries. But I don't know if he was sending a political
message or not. And at that point, we were free and clear for Mississippi and what I did
was two things with Mound Bayou, firmly in mind and having convinced OEO that yeah,
renovation would include an assembly of pre-Fab units that 60 by 20-foot modules,
the firm that had been contracted to build a health center and Watts by this time could come
down to Mississippi and build us a health center. And that would still be renovation and further
more it would be a lease purchase and that would be okay. We wouldn't be constricted by
the condition of no bricks and mortar. That's right, literally, that I had figured us out
and convinced OEO. I then started conspicuously wandering around Batesville in the north
of the Delta, quite a big town and lots of doctors looking for a place to renovate.
And my presence was noted although they weren't sure there what I was about. Then I gave a copy
of the grant to Joe Disparti. We were, Milesden had closed but we were already starting community
organization in Mound Bayou in Bolivar County, Mississippi. And I realized by this time to recapitulate
something earlier that what we had done, what I had done unconsciously was recapitulate Pholela
and Lamontville. Here we were in a 500 square mile rural area. It turned out to be of the Delta in
Mississippi and a public housing like Pholela and a public housing project in Boston like Lamontville
but that wasn't conscious. I gave the grant to Joe Disparti. She gave it to a doctor. She knew in
Batesville and it was on the governor's desk the next day. This was deliberate.
Was the grant to go to Batesville? The grant just said something rural.
And so they assumed it was going to be Batesville but in any case the grant was on the governor's
desk a day later. And the governor screamed at Shriver and OEO and Stennis screamed at Shriver
and OEO. There is a wonderful set of conversations of which I have the summaries
between Nils Y. Wessell, the president of Tufts and Governor Paul B. Johnson Jr.
There was a lot of newspaper publicity, the Jackson, Clarion, Ledger and elsewhere.
And a roar from the state medical society and from Dr. Archie L. Gray, the state health commissioner
whose political hero was Senator Theodore G. Bilbo. He told me and whose behaviors
fit that mold. I think I didn't mention that in addition to this veto provision the Southern
governors had agreed they thought well maybe we can tap into this money. So they agreed that grants
to institutions of higher education wouldn't be subject to veto. So maybe Ole Miss and University
of Alabama could tap into some of this. But there was nothing in the law I had sat down and realized
that said you couldn't give a grant to an institution of higher education in Massachusetts to do something
in Mississippi. We were accused with some correctness of having reinvented carpet bagging. But what
happened was the governor Johnson, Senator Stennis and everybody else suddenly discovered that we
were veto proof. The only guy who could veto our grant was the governor of Massachusetts and he
didn't care and wasn't about to and they couldn't stop it although they were screaming that it should
be stopped and all of the foreign agitator interloper plus their official position that they were
taking care of all of this and there was no need that they weren't meeting despite the data which
were appalling on black infant mortality rates and the like. Okay. So then there was an annual
clinical meeting of the American Medical Association in Atlantic City that spring of late 65 or early
1966. I would have to look it up to be precise and count and I and I wanted count with his other
accent for sure to be there arranged to meet with the leaders of the Mississippi State Medical Society
who would all be at the AMA meeting and discuss all of this. And so we went and we were received in their
hotel suite and it was all very courtly and polite and gentlemanly and they served us coffee and
we sat down to talk and we spent a lot of time talking they on their part about how this wasn't
needed and we really didn't need to intervene and they were taking care of it and my talking about
what the data showed and saying in fact that this would relieve them of a burden because if they
really attempted to undertake care of the poor the lines would be two miles long and we understood
how the system worked and we were back and forth on that and then they spent a lot of time
talking to us about how this certainly wasn't needed in Batesville and there were all of these
doctors and they were going to do this and that and I don't think there was explicit discussion
of being veto proof but it was understood and after we had spent about an hour and a half I said
well the only other place I had even given any thought to was Mound Bayou and it was like pulling
the lever on a slot machine and watching three oranges come up in their eyes and they said well
we still don't think you should do this but if you absolutely have to probably the only place
you could do it is Mound Bayou and and all this all black town and black community and there weren't
any white doctors and in effect I expressed great reluctance but I allowed them to force me to go
to where I really wanted to go in the first place and that worked as far as these leaders of the
state medical association but it didn't mean that all opposition was about to end. Now butressing
Mound Bayou I should interject Dr. John W. Hatch had gone down to Bolivar County, Mississippi to do the same kind of
scouting job that we had done in Georgia of what was on the ground and what was there and what
the needs were and what the potential resources were and this was in September it must have been
September of 65 and disappeared for three weeks we didn't hear from him we didn't know where he was
Mississippi was dangerous we grew very anxious and then he came back to Boston and reappeared at
Tufts he already had an appointment as assistant professor of preventive medicine on the faculty
and I said John where were you what were you doing he said well I picked cotton for three weeks
and then I understood fully the first time what a treasure we had he had lived in sharecropper
Shaq she had been all over Bolivar County, Mississippi he knew who the leaders were he knew what the needs were
he knew what the white circumstances were it should be made clear that we were looking at a period
of profound destitution in the Delta because the sharecropper system had collapsed with the
introduction of mechanized agriculture and one double row cotton picking machine replaced 100
Chercroppers and so they no longer needed their labor and with that among other things it wasn't
just unemployment and no money but no health care bad as it was since plantation owners no longer
had a vested interest in the health of this workforce and people squatting at best in old
sharecropper cabins and John scouted and knew and understood all of this I spent some months
then dealing not only with Dr. Archie L. Gray but with the state medical society the delta medical
society and the Bolivar County, Mississippi medical society all of which had meetings I got invited to speak
critically at the annual meeting of the delta medical society held at the country club in Greenwood
and gave my talk I learned something important there again gave my talk about
what the needs were who we were what needed to be done and what we planned to do
very straightforward and not judgmental and not accusing but speaking as a doctor
which with my stance throughout as the way to go and they then as I expected took a vote and the
vote was 50 to one to disapprove there was one black doctor that must have just been admitted
to the delta medical society the white medical society errands somebody and he
voted for it and 50 abstentions and if I didn't understand immediately I understood shortly
thereafter they invited me to come that evening to the country club dinner and dance being
courtly southerners and I said sure and I went to the dinner and I danced with the wife of the
president of the delta medical society and then I had to go to the men's room and I did and 30
doctors came in after me and I thought oh my god it's going to be like jail and they came up to me
quietly and they said that's a good thing you're trying to do you go ahead and do it
and it was my first lesson that there were people of goodwill in the white community and even
the white professional community who would respond to this as long as they were never exposed
publicly as doing so and that was my first lesson in that and so I this was while
driver was still stonewalling and I got on the plane and fludal Washington the next morning
because I knew he would I was quite sure he was sending his spy around after me to keep tabs
on what was happening and what I was doing and he would totally misunderstand the 50 to one vote
and not know about the abstentions and what they meant and fludal Washington to report that
and explain it and indeed in my digging around decades later I don't know how I found it but I
came across the report of his spy to driver there was one and he had gone out he hadn't been there
at the meeting but he'd gone out afterwards and interviewed everybody in various groups that I had
talked to all of whom told him lies that I had said things like we're coming whether you like it
or not we're going to shove it down your throats or whatever their fantasies that they thought would
be useful were the last meeting was with the Bolivar County Medical Society it was supposed to be
at the holiday in in Greenville and it got moved to the county cornhouse we had to meeting there
and I discovered that they had placed me in the printer the prisoner's dock but we had the meeting
and it was a repetition of the same thing and we began in Mumbai which was a question first of
of contracting to get the health center belt secondly starting to recruit and recruiting
people even with the promise of faculty appointments at Tufts was important doctors and nurses
and others to come to a small village of 2000 or less people in the Mississippi Delta in 1966
was not going to be easy there were questions of resources in terms of where we're going to live
and here was this black hospital the Knights and Daughters of Tabor the Knights and Daughters of Tabor the fraternal
order and it turned out a second smaller hospital of 20 beds the Sarah Brown by a different fraternal
order the United Order of Friendship that had split off after some schism and that both of them
despite having really abysmal quality troubles underfunded isolated under trained no different than
many small isolated rural hospitals but intensified by being black and isolated on those grounds
and underfunded because of that suffering from the sharecropper collapse in terms of revenue
that both of them were on the brink of bankruptcy and weren't even going to be able to meet
payroll and Tufts was really remarkable I think during those years Tufts and OEO I got
permission somehow to use our grant to rent the Knights and Daughters of Tabor hospital nurses residence
which was the old mansion in Mount Byurde the only three story brick building in town
that had been once occupied by Dr. T.R.M. Howard the flamboyant I forget his initials
Dr. T.R.M. Howard who had lived there and in fact it started the United Order of Friendship it was
nominally their nursing resident I think I rented it for $25,000 out of Tufts money so they could
meet their payroll at the two hospitals the upshot was that I sat down with George Allen a
consultant brought in by OEO and wrote a grant to OEO to merge those two hospitals one of them would
become a dental clinic that Knights and Daughters of Tabor would continue as the 40-bed hospital but no longer under
the control of fraternal orders but as a community hospital open to all of the poor of Bolivar County, Mississippi
and perhaps elsewhere and there was a long struggle to bring that about Dr. John Frankel (likely) or Frankel at this point
was the head of the office of health affairs and at one point I was told we think Dr. John Frankel (likely) or Frankel
actually owned the hospital for a week before we could create the new entity in this respect it turned out
that OEO made some significant mistakes and it never became a bonafide or real community hospital
they were supposed to have all kinds of community meetings for valid elections and participation
and it ended up not only under the with a board under representing entirely the two fraternal orders
but with the fraternal orders permitted to continue their business of selling health insurance
as well as admitting poor people free of charge and there was an inherent conflict of interest
outside of anything else because we're talking about the same people in effect as patients
and there were enormous quality of care problems understandably as well but we proceeded
talk some about the organization and operation
we Dr. John W. Hatch was community organizing in a way that almost never happened in OEO health center projects
in those years the resolution wasn't community control it was community participation in the creation
of community advisory councils or advisory committees or boards John patiently slowly organized
10 local health associations in northern Bolivar County, Mississippi we had specified northern bollover 500 square
miles 10 towns and their rural areas as all we would really be able reasonably to manage that was
14,000 somewhere between 12 and 14,000 black people we had taken our own full scale sentence
and done our own representative health survey so we knew something of the magnitude of the problems
we faced and what lay ahead of us and started recruiting through TOS while John spent all of this time
building these health organizations using as an organizational model but not any specific affiliation
to black Baptist Church that's the organizational form that people were familiar with understood
that experience running and could organize a local health association around and people recruited
themselves in addition we rapidly got from somewhere there appeared this remarkable Catholic
nurse midwife sister Mary Stella another nurse midwife from Denmark that had been working for the
WHO I'll see you Hanson Joe Disparti and Phyllis Cunningham and a group of other nurses both from
MCHR backgrounds in elsewhere a fair component of black nurses Chris Hansen, Christian Hansen, who had been
active in the movement lived in Dr. Robert Smith's house for a while recruited himself to come and join
and I ran as a physician I did everything I could not only to run advertisements but to
obtain publicity for this effort I went to the sheriff of Bolivar County, Mississippi and said we are going
to be this integrated crew and we're going to be fanning out in North Bolivar County, Mississippi and we are
going to be you know whites and blacks and we are going to be trying to do this good thing of
taking care of sick people who have no other good source of health care and it would be really
bad for Bolivar County, Mississippi and Mississippi if anything bad happened to us because I know I used to
be a journalist and I know people on every newspaper in the United States and if anything happened
to any of us it would be in headlines tomorrow in any newspaper in the United States and it would be
just like what happened in Selma and he said I am sure you're not going to have any difficulty
was another instance where a different background helped and indeed
they started to be once we really got going articles about us in the New York Times,
the Wall Street Journal, Time Magazine, Newsweek, the Associated Press,
all sorts of sources from former colleagues from those earlier years and they were what was
important about that was attracting recruits and giving us a shield against I think any kind of
opposition that would be too overt. In the beginning we were waiting for a clinical facility to be
built but we were doing community organization the surveys, home health visiting, public health
visiting, prenatal care with the midwives and staff training. We took advantage of lots of
other OEO programs and sent people off to learn how to local black people from Bolivar County, Mississippi
sent people off to learn how to be typists, secretaries, medical librarians,
some degree of technicians, community health workers. John built a staff which was the biggest
part of the health center in those years of the division called community health action which
was the community organization staffing. John early on recognized the need for environmental
intervention, all these people drinking water from the drainage ditch and living in collapse,
housing and with filthy outhouses and the like and recruited a black sanitarian, sanitary engineer
Andrew B. James from Ohio who came to head what became a major environmental program of digging wells
starting with slim but later with machines and digging privies, sanitary privies, teaching people
how to do it and educating people to what a health center was but we still weren't doing clinical
care because the health center hadn't been built and we realized that we had to begin that and so we
rented a vacant church percentage in Mound Bayou and used the living room as a waiting room,
two bedrooms as examining rooms in the kitchen as a lab and just started. I had recruited mostly
pediatricians Chris Hanson, Leon Kruger from a fancy suburb of Newton, Roy Brown
from somewhere else because the population skew was so much in a way similar to Pau'ala,
the young and the old and children in particular the median age in the population was 15,
the median age of male heads of household was 50, the whole generation in between was in Chicago
looking for jobs or St. Louis or wherever and so we said we're going to begin clinical care.
The first day there were maybe 15 people, they sent scouts, those people always do and the next
day there were 25 and the third day there were 100. Also it was not uncommon for me to get up in
the morning all the plans for housing development had fallen through and we had most of us
rented trailers, I mean Chris Hansen and many others were talking about guys with families and
children rented these big wide body trailers to put on lots in my view and live in
but we were overwhelmed and Dr. Aaron Shirley now in Jackson and Dr. Robert Smith these two black doctors
that had been so active in the movement had their own active practices in Jackson and somehow
nonetheless came up two days a week to help us out clinically because we just didn't have enough
staff and furthermore we had all these pediatricians taken care of adult people with hypertension and
diabetes and struggling and meanwhile slowly the health center itself was being built and we grew
and grew over the ensuing years. A second thing that had happened that should be mentioned is in
the summer of 66 when Columbia Point was open and thriving in its early stages, a senator
Senator Edward M. "Ted" Kennedy came to visit it this was the beginning of his primary interest in health and health care as his issue
got very taken by what he saw that was August of 66 we had dinner that night to discuss what to do he
went back to Washington and wrote legislation specifically creating an office of health affairs within
OEO with an initial budget of $50 million explicitly to build health centers that was the first time no
more research and demonstration but a major launch program with all of the attendant publicity and
community health centers started in a major way not just because there was funding but because so
many congresspeople suddenly realized that it would really be a nice thing to bring home a community
health center to their district although a majority of them were community sponsored we got the
building put together we assembled this growing staff recruitment was a continuing problem we never
could hire a black epidemiologist you couldn't get people professional people easily to come to
Mississippi and to live in this simple village and there were all of the questions that happened many
other places which were where you're going to send your kids to school what quality were the schools
and we understood that people were going to leave when their kids got older and were
in full scale operation by 1967 1967 early was when we did the church percentage and later that year was
when the health center finally got put together that one of the things that was the first part of
that sentence okay and so we were doing clinical care that is doctors seeing patients many of
whom had never seen a physician before in their life or if they had had never been examined because
the white practice was that the patient came out of the segregated waiting room sat across the
desk the doctor looked at them maybe listened to them didn't examine them and wrote a prescription
and we were different we had part time Aaron and Dr. Robert Smith Dr. Aaron Shirley and Dr. Robert Smith
we scored several other clues the recruitment of Harvey Sanders a black multiply qualified surgeon
from Holland down Mississippi a physician Charles Humphrey from Fayette and Dr. Helen Barnes a native
Mississippi and who had practiced in Greenwood after graduating medical school and then gone to
Brooklyn and trained he got her board certification in Ob-Gyn, and came back and looked at us when we were
still building a health center I chased her for two years and she said this is just a hole in
the ground as soon as you got the health center built call me again and I'll come this is a lady
you got to imagine Pearl Bailey with an MD who was vitally important and so we slowly grew and
I recruited David Weeks who had been running medical care for Aramco and Saudi Arabia and decided
his kids were old enough to come to the U.S. and I somehow convinced him that the cutting edge of
what was going on in the United States was in Mound Bayou Mississippi and he became our clinical
director so we had this triumvirate of Dr. John W. Hatch Andy James environmental Dave Weeks clinical
Dr. Helen Barnes and others the 10 health associations each sent delegates to an organization called the
North Bolivar County, Mississippi Health Council which was our official advisory group the other thing that
it happened that's worth noting is that we had tried to charter the health center as a not for
profit organization in Mississippi which it was and the law at that time was that the governor had
designed all not for profit charters and of course he wouldn't so we had to organize as a charitable
trust while we fought it in the courts and won but in the meantime it was a charitable trust which
meant that the trustees of Tufts University had no corporate protection and six or seven of them
put all of their assets in their wise names and became the trustees of the charitable trust that
was the health center one of many I think remarkable things that institution did the next thing John
Hatch did I had told him all about Pohlela. he was an enthusiastic gardener himself in any case
and we thought maybe we could get people to start some vegetable gardens because there was vacant
land around some of these shacks and the stuff that could be maybe used and we thought maybe we
get a hundred families to do vegetable gardens and thousands families raised their hands
and we realized that we were looking at people with agricultural skills now unemployed as
your croppers sitting on the richest land in the U.S. the topsoil 12 feet deep which was totally
devoted either to cotton or soybeans or under acreage restriction to nothing and there were around
Mound Bayou a minus number of black farmers that owned some land and they John and his crew organized
the North Bolivar County Farm Cooperative as part of the Southern Federation of Cooperative
organizations starting out with about 20 acres from one in 10 acres from another of the local black
farmers that was sitting idle at the donated dust nobody had tried truck gardening in the delta before
with this remarkable woman L.C. Dorsey as the deputy director to farm co-op LC had
been leading activist had left school in the ninth grade to work with Fannie Lou Hamer married
as a share married at 16 I think continued the activism married a sharecropper had six kids joined
us as a trainer of nurse aides early on did her GED at the health center one of the programs we had
we had an office of education and hired the retired principal of the Mound Bayou high school as its
director and we're making arrangements through our own connections to send young people
to schools and colleges around the country prep schools in some cases and universities and
professional schools in others because there were people around not only with high school degrees
but people with college and professional degrees here and there mostly working as teachers
in the usual traditional roles and in that first segment we sent seven people to nursing
to medical school two to Tufts the first two both of whom after they got their degrees in training
came back to work at the health center nursing school social work school pharmacy school
plain college two people getting masters degrees in clinical psychology at the University of
Washington in Seattle and two courses that Dr. John W. Hatch and Andy James organized or three
Andy brought in people from all around the country and trained the first
ten registered black sanitarians in Mississippi history all of whom after Andy's course local people
went down to Jackson and took the exam and passed a second course that we called a college prep
professional preparatory professional that senior staff taught
a number of whom ended up going to college or professional school particularly at Stony Brook a
little later on and the farm co-op we went up and got a big grant from the Ford Foundation
and John and L.C. organized what became a 500 acre irrigated triple crop mechanized partly mechanized
farm involving somewhere between four and six thousand persons from Bolivar County, Mississippi
who planted the vegetables raising vegetables instead of cotton or soybeans and the way it worked
is they were full members of the co-op they were co-op boards parallel to the local health associations
but different and they traded their labor both for some immediate income and then shares in the crop
and grew over the next several years literally thousands I think tens of thousands once we got to
500 acres of tons of vegetables okra beats sweet potatoes yams high protein corn potatoes
greens of all kinds cukes you name it we grew it and indeed for a while ran a meat locker
and started to sell surplus in the open local market and even had dreams for a while of getting
a cannery and growing soul food it could be canned and sold in the northern ghettos we had the
backing of the people in Minnesota that on the jolly green giant and John and I Dr. John W. Hatch and
I went up and talked to them and said what we would like to do and could we call it the jolly black
giant and they thought that was a wonderful idea and the government had a cannery 30 miles away
that had been in white hands and gone bust and economic development agency and wouldn't give
it to us it became clear the government was interested in palliative programs for black communities
but not in capital programs and entrepreneurship and real things that they would run and operate
one of the problems that faced in rural Bolivar County was that people didn't have cars they didn't
have access to the center how how did you do outreach the health council we kept shifting as many
programs and slurry programs as we could to the health council which got independently funded
uh uh bioeo that became a practice and so they ran we had a parallel organization that was
separate in the farm co-op and the farm co-op board and its staff the health council also ran
an emergency food program that was really a WIC program for mothers and infants
and a library and bookstore as a cultural center and a some of an early childhood intervention program
in the 10 satellite communities where we had places where initially people could
uh become in each of these places to be then transported to and from the health center because
we are again talking 500 square miles and a lot of towns and so the health council together with us
but under their control organized the bus transportation network is that operated through all of the
10 towns of Bolivar County to and from the health center but around and it became not only and we
had ambulances and other vehicles for staff and particularly the visiting nurses but also became
to some extent extended opportunities for economic mobility you had a way of getting from
rural area to the town where there might be a job or to another town where there might be a job
so the health council had its own set of activities and also we had used our leverage and they did
they started inventing programs of their own in round lake a small town north of us a remarkable woman
Mrs. Robinson recognized a need that we hadn't fully seen or understood that there were all of these
isolated elderly folks living alone whose kids and grandkids had gone to St. Louis
or Chicago and were often in desperate circumstances hungry isolated and needed help so the first
thing she did was organize a meal program and then an entire social network program where they all
got together three or four times a week and gotten not only got their meal but had a range of
activities with each other all day so they were not isolated despite it was extended families
support didn't work that well because so many people as in South Africa were gone somewhere else
looking for work so they were participant in everything it's worth mentioning
an episode I think unique in OEO's history and a part of this story who were doing clinical care
midwifery health education professional training growing food repairing houses plantation shacks
with screens a variety of ways of going after food including the food co-op the farm co-op in particular
intervening in effect in all of what are now called the social determinants of health the things
that we're making people sick in the first place because these environmental circumstances
were such a major factor in what was making people sick in the first place we really tired
over and over again of seeing infants with infectious diarrhea and dehydration more a
bond from drinking water in the drainage ditch and if we were lucky finding a vein to stick an
needle and to rehydrate them put them in the hospital and what and send them back to drink some
more water from the drainage ditch it was ineffective economically but much more important in human
terms needed this other kind of intervention and now almost 50 years later people are finally
starting to focus once again on social determinants of health and the fact that it is not just
medical care alone that needs to be changed. Dr. Geiger, you have given us a wonderful summary in the
last two minutes of exactly what the tough delta health center did we have taken too much of your
time this has been fascinating but I'm wondering if you would tell us something about the situation
in which you collect a mound by you and your career since that time. Okay two things should be noted
out of all of this and they involve hundreds of thousands professional people by now so it is
hardly just myself and my colleagues there are now more than 1,200 community health centers in
the United States in every state and territory with their satellites they are providing care at
a little more than 8,000 different sites if you put all of that on a map it looks like a map in
the United States with measles there are so many of these places they have they take care of a little
more than 20 million people low income whites and blacks mostly minority and Hispanic and Native
American people urban and rural and in the migrant streams and in public housing projects and in
schools public schools and that is what has grown with the input of thousands of other health
professionals and thousands of other communities as they have evolved now under the rubric of
health education and welfare now health and human services and the Bureau of Primary Care
they have since 1975 become unique in the American health care system in the following
respect it stems from all of this early work every community health center federally qualified
community health center has to be by law a non-for-profit organization with an elected board 51% of whose
members must be current patients at the health center there is no other part of the American
health care system where patients have this kind of voice in the policies and direction of
their own medical care so that needs to be mentioned is really the most important thing that has
gone on since those days in personal terms in 1971 I think or they're about I switched from
tough medical school to the new then new medical school at the state University of New York at Stony Brook
on Long Island and it's part of a process in which the health council understanding that it could
stay with toughs they weren't like some piece of suitcase that I carried around they could stay
with toughs they could come to Stony Brook they wanted to look at Wisconsin and Meharry Medical College they made
what I believe is the only set of reverse site visits by a community group going to these places
and saying well if this project comes to you what will you offer our community in the way of
scholarships for example and they ultimately chose Stony Brook and something like 19 people
that I can count from Bolivar County in our area went to the state University of New York on
Stony Brook on scholarship and got their degrees and that was more even than we had done at any
single institution before them I had a difficult time as Stony Brook I'm a city boy I am fine in
the boondocks of Mississippi or other rural areas or South Africa Sydney and Emily Carc by the way
and their colleagues came and Dr. John B. Cassel came and visited both Columbia Point and the Delta
Health Center in Mound Bayou we have come full circle Dr. John W. Hatch I should add
cases not on your list to interview was left to do a doctorate in public health at the University
of North Carolina School of Public Health the minute you got his doctorate they hired him
as a member of their faculty he went on to become the Ward Keenan Professor of Public Health
the first African-American to hold an a doubt share in the health professions at that university
and through the Christian Medical Council and a whole variety of foundations and other
organizations to which he was consultant became really an international force for community
health organization health care delivery and change I left Stony Brook because there was going
to be there was just forming a new medical school in New York City called the City University
of New York Medical School that was going to be explicitly devoted to training people for primary
care in underserved urban areas of New York with a particular focus on the recruitment admission
and recruitment of minority and low income students to overcome some of the traditional barriers
we admitted students upon their graduation from high school and combined college and the
first years of medical school a low tuition they would go on to regular schools for the
clinical years to get their M.D., under an agreement in which they would pay back with at least
two or more years of service as primary care physicians in underserved mostly urban areas of the
city and state in effect the opportunity to train people to do what I and all the other community
health center people had done and indeed our clinical campus became which I helped organize
became eight community health centers in New York City and that's where our students had their
first clinical experience so I found in the Department of Community Health and Social Medicine
at the City University of New York Medical School now called the Selfie Davis School of Biomedical
Education and I was there from 1978 until I nominally retired in I think 1996 or some such a year
although I continue to teach every year keep an office there and be active have since
been very very much involved with both medical education organizations public health organizations
national medical fellowships which is the major NGO that supports medical education and other
education else related education of minorities now with a new organization called Medical Legal
Partnerships that puts lawyers in every community health center in hospital at can to start addressing
the legal problems that are making poor patients sick in the first place,
Lausy housing, molding the walls, exploitative landlords, exploitative job bosses
and other legal difficulties which has the wonderful effect of sensitizing the medical staff
to find out about these social environmental problems that are contributing so much to the
illness of these populations so I am still rattling around trying to disturb the peace
and keep some of these efforts going through other organizations.
At 87 which is what I am now I don't quite have the stamina for doing some of the things that
went on in the 60s and 70s and 80s but there are other roles and one of the most important ones
I just for example have been supervising more than $4 million grant to national medical fellowships
that puts minority students on elective clerkships in community health centers.
The most important task at this point is to do what I can to see that there becomes a next
generation of people in the professions and outside the professions that has this orientation and
does this work. I would just like to conclude by pointing out that the Institute of Medicine
and the National Academy of Science and Honor Dr. Jack Geiger quote for creating a model of the
contemporary community health center to serve the poor and disadvantaged in contributions to the
advancement of minority health that is an understatement if anything thank you very much Dr. Geiger
for sharing your life with us. Well my pleasure folks. Can I ask you a medical social medical
this has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of
African American History and Culture.